do you both learn something new from
every film that you do on every set no
no you know you try and uh yeah yeah you
sure you constantly try to find
something new you know and you try to
stretch yourself and challenge yourself
so you know you're you're seeking
characters and in an environment in
which you can do that um so yeah so yeah
you try and definitely be open to to
that it's always a constant adding to
your well of knowledge that that you
know an experience it's all it's what
it's about
yeah so with come and find me what did
you - anything new that you learned it's
not really you know uh her and I working
together on this film why I pride myself
in being Luke trying to be a
professional right and I know you do the
same
try yes it and you're incredible at it
but it's also it's a it's good to have a
combination of being professional but
also having a lot of fun on set and not
taking it too seriously where you can't
enjoy yourself when you're not actually
rolling and and so just creating a
beautiful environment for the cast and
crew yeah and a safe place to kind of
experiment and test yourself and that
that is going back to Erin said you know
making sure that when we come off stay
at stage well that yeah she's stage
actors in my head Oh set that you are
supported and and you have a good bunch
of people around you that you you know
honor you and you want to honor them
return so um yeah it was very much that
on this project but I do think you're
always looking for something to learn
and take with you right
we always hear from successful people
that they work and I'm just going to say
tales just in case there's any children
listening off to to be successful do you
feel that the two of you have worked
harder than others to achieve what you
have or
does it sometimes I mean you know I
noticed so there's a combination of so
many things also luck that's a lot to do
with it yeah it really really does but
you do have to come prepared during
those lucky moments and so and don't be
afraid to grow yeah I know also when you
driven for the right reasons I think
it's very clear the actors that are
doing what they do for sheer passion and
love for what they do I know that's our
case and I think it's very clear when
you walk in a room I think there's no BS
if I'm allowed to say that yeah what you
know it's not like there's only so much
you can pretend and there's so much
front you can can come into a room with
at the end of the day it's it's the core
of you that matters it's it's your it's
your talent that gets you further so
Locke and all these things yes you have
an opportunity and it's what you you
come to the table with and if you come
to the table with the right things the
right people will notice they go wow
that was great done done
boom drop the mic that's great